[Music]
the NHS is facing its toughest winter
ever
oh
battered by a pandemic
crippled by staff shortages we've got
two patients coming in but that's full
oh one is coming in at 16.
and millions across the country left
waiting for care
[Music]
the ambulance and its crew have been on
the road for less than an hour
and Gigi and John are already responding
to their third call GP unable to contact
on the floor so someone's Fallen it says
9pm last night she is a 78 year old
female patient
so she's quite elderly it's a category 2
emergency
they got a special alarm that they
compress but sometimes when it's in the
they get a call in the morning because
their carer has found them on the floor
but they've been there all night
basically thank you Gigi and John have
to be prepared for anything
hello
they see and treat our most vulnerable
in their most desperate moments did you
press your button today yes yeah
and what did you need the ambulance for
I'd fall it out of my bed oh okay I
couldn't get up I see Elizabeth is 78
she spends most of her life in this room
I've had knee replacement yeah hip
replacement okay I've got plantar
fasciitis in both feet oh okay and my
sciatic nerve is trapped ouch so you're
in pain oh dear yeah a quarter of
non-life-threatening 999 calls last
winter involved fools what are you
struggling with at the minute
getting to my bed at night
Elizabeth has a carer who visits three
times a day it's not enough how often do
you fall
work twice a day twice a day so quite
often patients like Elizabeth are more
at risk than ever
this winter they face a potential rise
in flu and covid ambulance response
times at an all-time high Phil just go
forwards a little bit and the care
system short of a hundred and sixty five
thousand stars
um do you want us to bring you anything
before we leave
thousand pounds I work for the NHS yeah
do you got it ready all right all the
best Elizabeth okay it looks like she's
had quite a few ambulances maybe
probably about 200 in the last year if
there was a carer there help her out of
bed every time get her some food and
this is what happens a lot is if when
there's no carers coming in
they tend to fall over because they need
to do everything themselves
ambulance response times across the
country
are growing longer than ever
responding to life-threatening calls
takes 30 percent longer than before the
pandemic
while getting to emergencies like heart
attacks and strokes takes twice as long
it can be quite disheartening sometimes
hearing across the radio all of those
calls that are waiting for an ambulance
because there's no and this is available
patients can't be moved from a e into
those different Wards or in the social
care so there's no space to put the new
patients when we're bringing them in
which then causes further ambulance
delays we've been with this ambulance
crew since this morning we're on our way
to see our seventh patient we've seen
six already and it's only halfway
through a normal shift
it's just come in about 30 seconds ago
it's for someone who's having a severe
allergic reaction uh their lips are
going blue
so I'm just going to come around the
back if that's all right so if you just
take some nice big deep breaths for me
Maggie is nine years old her mother
Rochelle called Emergency Services after
becoming frantic with worry brilliant
that's all really good that's really
good
has anything like this ever happened
before
what happened four years ago so I I
think
yeah your face yeah
and the same thing I'm very sick but she
meant she's weak yeah
Maggie's condition is now stable but
Gigi and John decide to take her to
hospital for further tests
the a e department at the Queen
Elizabeth Hospital in Woolwich is one of
the busiest in the country
they've been facing the sort of pressure
usually only seen in winter but all
through the summer as many as 600 people
a day
a job made much harder because the trust
has 70 patients medically fit for
discharge but can't leave because they
have no Community social care package in
place the impact is huge we describe it
sort of like almost like firefighting we
adapt we have to adapt we have to carry
on doing the best that we can for each
individual patient but I think the
challenges of trying to see patients in
places
in areas where we wouldn't normally see
them adds its extra layer of complexity
those who are admitted from a e come
through here the clinical decisions unit
we're trying to see as many patients as
we can get the treatment as quickly as
we can but one of the challenges is
obviously trying to find the right space
for them for example in this Bay we
normally have four patients four beds
but to meet our demands we've had to
create a fifth bed
which is another person there have to be
as stable as possible because obviously
there's no specific oxygen areas for
them increases the workloads for the
nursing and Doctor staff on daily basis
people come here to find out what their
problem is we want to deliver that we
want to deliver the care we can if we're
not able to you know get the Diagnostics
if we're not able to bring them in when
they need to be in to provide the
treatment when we need to it's a
challenge all around
Anne-Marie has been a nurse for 34 years
there's little she hasn't seen so we've
got a Physio and occupational therapy
assessment that says that you need every
day she fights a constant battle to try
and find the right care for her patients
who are well enough to leave and enough
beds for those who aren't moreover for
me this is my local hospital this is
where I would bring people that mean
something to me either my friends or my
family and actually I want to know that
when my friends and family need an
ambulance number one the ambulance can
get to them because they're not being
held in an ed somewhere and then when my
families come into Eden the decision is
made that they need to be admitted that
actually I can then say okay that's fine
because don't worry we'll have a bed for
you on board four
around half a million people
are thought to be waiting for a care
assessment or funding
Carol has terminal cancer she needs
round-the-clock treatments but rather
than being treated in hospital
she's receiving Community Care in a
hospice
and I suppose it makes your family feel
quite relieved that you're receiving
such expert care that's right
what we have got
we will
I've never been to work upstairs
but when I say this
it's like going into a fairy tale
I'm just too well
to receive
any sort of treatment
not Machinery okay
it would have been two or two number
three put together
if you'd been receiving treatment
somewhere else
Harold's life prolonging care like other
services across the social care system
is under pressure
hospices and Care Homes are facing
multiple challenges we are trying to
recruit and retain stuff in a limited
pool and a geographical pool but also a
sense of how many staff you've got
qualified with that experience within
this era to do the job that we
specifically do here
that growth of patient need population
complexity of symptoms particularly
post-pandemic where people have an
Access Healthcare in the same way over
the last two or three years you were
looking at people with much later stage
disease and that's really complicated so
we'd love to do more but our limiting
factor is Staffing
even at 90
s living with cat ER and diabetes
Catherine is fiercely independent that's
the purchase right okay she receives
support from her local hospice and her
family but she's at risk of Rapid
decline we are Catherine knows
eventually she will need more Specialist
end-of-life Care in the community I know
there's no treatment for me to to have
for around my life any longer so
we'll just accept what comes my way
if it can happen at the end of my life
then I you know don't mind up tolerated
I know my daughters will do everything
possible for me to have a good ending
won't you I mean I rely on them
and
they're looking after me now and I
couldn't have two better daughters
really
that makes me feel
sad I'm gonna leave them behind
Catherine knows what it's like to not
have access to care
her husband Peter had Alzheimer's and
deteriorated rapidly in front of the
family's eyes
we had a particular incident and it all
it was an awful incident here we had
nobody because we weren't in the system
in the care system
we we had to survive an awful four days
of Dad here without any support no
support at all and it was horrendous
Rebecca has been caring for this
community for a decade her job is now
harder than ever the patients she cares
for increasingly need more specialist
services and delays throughout the
Health Care system
make the problem much worse it's quite
immense pressure because the patients we
tend to see
they are getting complex there's a lot
who are not able to get the care in need
because of how it is nationally in terms
of access so there are more people who
need care and carers available very very
much so so more more patients are
needing that but the availability of it
and the quality of care which is
available is quite minimum
[Music]
Health and Care must be seen as one
joined up system all parts of it need to
be supported funded and staffed if one
part breaks down the other parts will
too and it's happening now
and people
are suffering
scanners